hey it's me again um
i'm here to tell you guys another one of
my bad but good stories
we don't i'm going to talk about the
holiday time 10 that is thanksgiving day
um i was thinking last night about
my first my first christmas stuff the
one i could remember as a child i was
about seven years old and then i had a
had a babysitter named celine and she
would uh she had molested me before she
had me she had forced me to lay down on
the floor in the bathroom and she
got on top me and had sex with me you
know and i didn't i didn't i didn't i
didn't know what was going on with see
what she was doing but anyway
when christmas time would come around
she her she had to babysit me
and uh my brothers and sisters while
while my
dad mother we had a they had a club they
had to go to work at the club that night
and um i remember she made me she made
me she made me she made me
do all sex on her and i remember i
remember i remember i remember i
remember her [ __ ] stuck oh god damn i
should stop so
that [ __ ] smell but i remember when
she made me do it i kind of d
i kind of liked it because i liked i
liked it because even though i was a
little boy
i was always a little horny little
bastard i know i didn't i didn't even
know what sex was
but i was always a little horny little
bastard i don't even know why you know
i'd watch my uncle monty [ __ ] i'd
sneak up and peek through the doors and
[ __ ] like that
and watch my sister's hanging out i was
always a weird little [ __ ]
but uh when she came when she started
babysitting us well anyway that one time
the first time we had done something i
went into the bathroom
and she was sitting on the toilet and
she had her legs kind of open and i went
and i
went and asked her could i see her to
your vagina i was i was about six years
old
and she laid me on the floor and she but
she went up she
she got on top me i don't know what she
was i don't know what she was doing but
i mean
it was kind of cool with me you know so
that really made me a little horny freak
so then
that one time at christmas she had me
eat her [ __ ] so
every time she started to come over and
and uh and
watch us you know she would she and she
and the rest of the kids were there too
but she would make her go to sleep you
know she
she knew how to she knew how to keep me
up making sure donald if you stay up
i'll give you extra ice cream she would
tell me my brother me and my brother
will always stay along with the other
but my little brother would always they
wouldn't they would
they would crash hard i mean they would
cry sorry but i was always even to this
day
it was always a night out i like to be
up at night i like you know i just i
just i go to bed at 12 1 o'clock at
night like any nothing so
for me to stay with her for 12 o'clock
with nothing plus i got to get some free
ice cream and get to eat some [ __ ] you
know
so um that went on for some time and
then
i had my my my
my cousin my cousin came by so this
happened this this particular incident
was
happening around thanksgiving time had
my cousin come over there and he was a
little horny bastard too he kept these
porno magazines and like i say i never i
didn't i didn't really know what sex
wasn't like that
but i would i knew he had him and he
would keep him in that little little
little like little dresser already he
would always bring over a house
and then when he'd go to sleep and i
would i would take him out right i would
take him out and i would look at them
you know i had never masturbated nothing
like that
but i always i wanted it it made me it
made it made me want to
it made me want to stuff it made me want
to do something you know i knew a little
kid
so one day celine was over there and
when she had me to
when she had me eat her [ __ ] she she
she she
fondled me like this you know i'm like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] she what the
[ __ ] you doing i just say
what the [ __ ] you doing so when she did
it it kind of you know it keeps stroking
my [ __ ] it kind of feel good
like damn that [ __ ] so the more she did
it the more i was i was oh god
i was doing all that [ __ ] and um
so the next time i got my cousin's
magazine
i said well maybe if i do myself i'm
telling y'all i said well if i do myself
maybe i can get the same feeling i was
getting winston was sucking
i was sucking on my [ __ ] so i remember
i had i had turned this i had this
magazine but just
was just he had these magazines with
these with these for some reason they
were all these big chested white women
with big legs and that's why i like them
i like me some big leg women
and then one guy had the girl with her
legs open and and she would
and he he was doing her like celane had
me do the lady and i was like damn
and i said damn that's what the lady be
having me do you know so
i said damn so i said i've been chopping
the city to take my [ __ ] out my so this
is my first time whacking
so i whacked my [ __ ] off you know
and it was it was weird because when i
would get my when i get to get my
cousins magazines
now for all you fellas you know i for
some reason the pages inside the
magazine would be stuck together so i
couldn't i couldn't get to them then
pages they'd be stuck together
so i'm so i know and i went i got real
quiet because i knew
he because he said somebody been [ __ ]
somebody would [ __ ] around in my door
man
somebody been [ __ ] around in my
[ __ ] drawer and i would be
sitting here
so i got real sick so anyway but i
couldn't understand
why them damn magazines but the pages
were stuck together so i just started
ripping off what i
it was real real clever the way i did
because i was always a sneaky little
[ __ ]
and i remember when i would go i would
go take they take the tip of the pages
man
i'll give you a page and i'll go and
open it in the book and then in the
bathroom no so let me back up
so the first time i had an orgasm orgasm
on the particular i had
a had like a center fold i orgasmed on
this center fold and when i closed the
center fold back up and i put it away
when i went to go take it out again it
was stuck together
i said oh that's what the [ __ ] happened
so wait so now one day one day my cousin
caught me in the drawer
going to get the magazine man what you
doing he's outside his brown
so he's going to come out a little he's
going to clown me right donald been
going to my book she's been taking him
in the bathroom i know what he's doing
that's why he beat up late at night i
know that's what he'd be doing
so i got it i said now my i said so what
uncle my uncle ronnie
your all the pages in your other
magazine all them stuck together
everybody laughed and that was that so
then
then okay now now the next christmas
comes along was it it was either
christmas
it was christmas or or new year's one of
the one of those
holidays and we the
the people the people's cousins and [ __ ]
would come over our house and everybody
would
we you know we had we had always had a
lot of company [ __ ] on holidays so my
dad would cook these
barbecue pits and all these all this
[ __ ] going on well let me back let me
back let me back up let me talk about
christmas gifts
i always feel like charlie brown because
if it would be like it'd be like the
rest of the kids got you know all these
banners expensive bikes and i get a used
one you know or they get
they get nice new jeans i gotta get a
pair that was too short all right or
they get
converse all-stars and i get some some
abc pro club pro kids or some [ __ ] like
that does this seem like i was always
the black sheep
and i'd sit there in the corner and cry
and think you know i was always just sad
you know
since when crimson came up and and um
we had these the people there their
cousins would come over their house so
two two cousins named ben adrian
they were little girls they were nice
looking little girls so
he's kind of like one of them and she's
kind of like me you know and so
the kids would play this game and they
caused this game they called it a hide
and go get them
i didn't know what go get them what the
[ __ ] that's the first time we played the
game i hit him when i went to go get
i hit him i remember i caught the girl
caught up with the girl they had her the
corner and
in the parkway the cars were and she's
like what you going to do what you go
and i'm like
i took off running sorry the other way
just so wrong
he ran but i was about not gonna talk
about nine or ten something like that
the next time that happened we played
the hide and go get him thing i told my
big brother my big brother say man you
supposed to man when you when you get to
go hide
you're supposed to make them give you
some give me give me some water you know
give him something get go
do the hump on him or something so this
is the truth
i got the same girl i guess i knew she
was getting caught on purpose it's like
it was it was like the carport where the
car that
we never feel it was it was a buick
riviera and the front because the lights
do like this
and and the car was sitting here and so
i brought she we got caught her in front
of the car
like i said i was always and i when i
started i started i think
that's my first time feeling lust i just
i wanted to [ __ ] her i wanted to [ __ ]
her
and i and i i i never i didn't know any
i had never kissed a woman i know
anything about you being stimulated by
kissing a woman like that i just know i
feel like
she made me feel something i never felt
and i remember when i
got on i grabbed her by the waist and i
started kissing her so you know first i
grabbed her waist and i was i was scared
to kiss her and she said
she said come on do something take your
tongue out or something kiss me
okay so anyway we started to do the
french kiss thing
and i remember when i started i grabbed
her by the waist i remember she started
she had these little red shorts on and i
said you know this is real embarrassing
and i started humping on you know and my
little my little thing i i kind of shot
some i kind of shot on her opinions
right
and she said she said louis peed on me
lose peed on me
so my same cousin he told me that night
he said he said man
they told me you got a nut today i said
no because you know christmas time
my mother's always keep these nuts on
the on the table i said no no no the
nuts isn't on the table in here
they told me you you you busted and
you did something like that i said no
there's nothing on the table
so in another time around thanksgiving
time
when i went out of town with arkansas
little rock arkansas
and uh
there was this we would go to this i'd
forgive me that we would go to this
church on sundays and wednesdays and
sundays and we'd go on wednesday
this little white chick ice like her
name was sami
sandy or something but she had this long
blonde hair his big deep blue eyes and
these
big big thighs and her mother would make
her wear i just i guess we were about
10 or 11 or something like that 12
something like that her mother would
always make her wear those little skirts
and then when she did something about
when she was a little girl she didn't
know what was going on when she sat down
their legs like that the skirt would
come up
and always see her she had the prettiest
i remember she had white peach fuzz
underneath i'm in the white piece and
i'm like
now i'm not like nine or ten years old
and now this is just turning me on
and i'm sitting but but like i said i
didn't know i didn't know i didn't know
i was being stimulated i didn't know i
was
what was really going on you know so i
remember i looked at it and i kind of
i just every time i would they kind of
knew we kind of because every time we
tried we would always sit next to each
other and they kind of was we're kind of
saying something but not really saying
nothing well they're just friends so one
day
when they pass the collection plate
around i said i know what i'll do
i'll drop the dollar on i'll drop the
dollar on her and then go down and get
the dollar so when i dropped the dollar
the dollar went right where i wanted it
to go the dollar the dollar was down in
the world
so i remember when i went down while i
put me i said no no i'll get it
remember when i went down to get the
dollar i remember i remember
like the inside of her thyroid i mean i
i just want to know what a white leg
feel like and i squeezed i was like and
i remember
my god i'm so embarrassed i remember
going i'm going to say
like when i got the dollar and the poor
girl
she didn't she didn't know what to she
didn't know what she didn't know what
the hell was i didn't really know what
was going but she didn't know what was
going on she kind of looked like
didn't anybody see that so now then i
didn't think nobody's not
and i'm not they're not now i'm paranoid
because i don't so the next time we went
back
mom said uh uh uh uh uh you sit down
here now i don't know i don't know what
your mom said you sit down here and her
mom and
my brother and she was kind of it it
looking at i didn't go back no i didn't
want that somebody gonna kill me
that was when this happened and uh
now as i got older we would go to we
would go down
on the on on veterans day
and on the fourth of july my dad will
cook these these really really big big
big big lunches and dinners and
everything and he really didn't like me
drinking so
what i would try to do is i'll try to
sit out in the car and drink
and i go in there and my dad was always
like i don't know what he what he meant
he would always
always down me or cut me in some kind of
way
he would always say something negative
to me that would really affect me god
blessed me he just didn't know
you know but he would just always say
something and it would be around all
this company
and it would really affect me to hurt me
so i would go sit in the room and i was
sitting in the living room and i was
just
you know just why why why does everybody
like me why does everybody think that
my mind was just why does everybody just
why doesn't people why don't people like
me why am i such a i start thinking i'm
why am i such a bad person you know
why i'm not writing a bad guy why am i
such a bad person and um
that started me kind of with that with
that with that negative thinking you
know it seemed like only
to this day i still feel that way around
my family i'll get i'll get there later
so one one one one thanksgiving one
chris whatever holiday we were all
in a big dining room in a dining hall
somewhere this is after i had my child
my daughter i had my daughter in my arms
my dad said to me look at louis
playing daddy
now i don't know how he meant that i
heard somebody say one time it's not
what you say to me that makes me mad
it's what i say to myself when you stop
talking
but no [ __ ] that i know he was he was
calling me a sorry
i see he was saying i'm a worthless
father you know and that was
that was dude that that that that that
that cut me so [ __ ] bad i wanted to
beat him i wonder i want to i want to
strangle his ass you know
that's how mad it made me i want to beat
my dad i want to fight him i want to say
[ __ ] this [ __ ] man
come on outside dude let's get these
[ __ ] up let's duke and get them
up you know
that's you know god my dad my fault but
god bless me he's dead right now but
i mean he started that kind of [ __ ] you
know but going
going down going back a little more
that's what i was thought about
this this i'm gonna this i'm gonna tell
y'all something around quick holiday
time
we were and and and i i i did something
but
you know i can't go to jail for it
because but this is something i have
this is something right i have never
ever ever in my life talked about
um my therapist said i i talked about
turing and she's like i should talk
anyway
i was always a scary little kid i was
always scared to fight
always scared to fight so it's this guy
named james
and uh he wasn't that big of a guy he
just had that you know what that brutus
i was so scared of the poor guy i never
would i never would even tell anybody
well me and my friend we put together
these dirt bikes you know
these these these these uh they call
them them bmx spikes and we put them
we didn't really really they we we would
we would go to the mall and steal all
these nice parts these rims and all
these different lights
everything on the bike was stolen but we
put it he was we would put him together
so one day i would and then this guy
james would play basketball in the park
down behind my house at night
he would go down there with his with his
whoever he's winning whatever and
i guess he wanted to be a professional
basketball player god bless him he won't
be one now but anyway
but he was so so one day i was walking
through the park coming from the store
walking through the park
you say lewis come here man you're like
what's up
you should give me that bike
[ __ ] imma beat your
[ __ ] ass
don't take my bike god [ __ ] give me the
bike [ __ ] hit me stomach boom
knocked the win on me and took the bike
put the bike down the ground still
playing basketball man i couldn't know i
was so scared i didn't know what to do
when i'm told my grandma wear your bike
oh man i took it to the store and
somebody stole it that was my life
awesome but i don't know all the time
but i was scared of james and big jane
took it from me
you know so i'm a dog lover and i had a
friend of mine who had these very rare
german shepherds
now this particular german shepherd he's
got a low back he's you know
he's his legs are short in the back he's
got black back and
brown he's really pretty long facing his
big ears
my friend just like my sister he gave us
two he gave him gave her one and he gave
me one so i had my german shepherd and
i named him i named him king you know
and king and uh
i would i would walk him and he but he
and when i let him out the back he would
he would run off for some reason so
one day king came up missing so we later
i saw him down in the park with jane
james had him on the leash
i said this [ __ ] got my dog but
i was scared to say something
and i got to i was making i was making
shoes for myself ah
that probably my dog that and but every
time when i walk by the dog
you know you can see you can see he was
he was he he knew me
he knew me said man why my dog looking
like he know you i still didn't say
nothing
so one day my my friend's dad had just
had his wine and we drank a bottle of
wine i went down
and i and i went down to the park and i
said hey man there's people without with
them playing basketball
i say [ __ ] you better give me my
dog and my [ __ ] bike
you going to get your ass up today
before i could finish talking he he
slapped me
bam he smacked me pow
i went on like a big back up [ __ ]
[ __ ] i walked home and didn't do
nothing
i sat there about 15 minutes i said [ __ ]
this [ __ ] i went back down again
hey man i gotta take a little more you
better give me he said
he said [ __ ] you and he he kicked the
bike on the ground he took that [ __ ]
leash and he grabbed my [ __ ] dog
he took my [ __ ] dog when he
don't [ __ ] with my dog all the fear left
me
i don't know it's like the devil got at
me
that's why i'm crying my my dog man he
swung my dog by that
that goddamn [ __ ] now my dad had
had a drawer and he kept two
snub knows in that drawer now when he
left the house
he would lock up his room and like i
said i was a sneaky little [ __ ]
so i knew
i watched mission impossible and saw
that black guy put a card in the door
and get the door open
but god damn i got in the door and i
took the screwdriver i know my daddy
drove
and i got that little black snowman was
out there mother had never
never shot a gun and i remember i
remember when i picked it up
i'm like damn it what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] i'm wrong put in my pocket i drink
some more that wine
and i went down to the park and i i
guess i don't know what it was got to do
whatever
the whole man was down there by himself
now when you play basketball in that
particular part
you get you got a south end you got a
north end if you come down the hill on
the north end
if he's facing this way he just can't
see you so i came down there too i came
down and i said hey man
i had the gun in my back pocket and i've
been back in my pants i thought
i watched him on dude on tv hey man i'm
finna get my [ __ ] i'm finna get my [ __ ]
now i don't give a [ __ ] do or die i'm
trying to get my [ __ ]
you put the boys man you want your must
want your ass kicked again i said when i
pull that i pull that pistol out
he's all [ __ ] and he i mean i never saw
a [ __ ] run that fast he ran that fast
the dog went that way
of course i never got the dog right off
i never got but anyway he ran that way
now where the oh my god
god hold the hopes police don't get me
for this god damn i got god i got to get
off my chest
they had it they had a gate that goes on
this side of the park and you could jump
through the gate you go behind on i'm
not going to say what's the name
there's a store back there now where the
trucks had an alley dock where they
backed the trucks in
it was a trash can where they threw all
this stuff in the trash
and you could go back there at least go
back and smoke whatever you like
about that much room behind the trash
can and when i ran behind him i knew
i knew he went back there i knew but
i think that's the only time in my life
that i because i you know people would
really make me mad with things they
would do to me but i was such a [ __ ] i
would just get so mad i
said him i said one day i'm gonna blow
somebody's [ __ ]
and i remember i remember the poor man
was down i'll never forget
i'll never forget the way he looked when
he saw me come by that dress in with
that pistol
and i thought about my dog and i
put one in his stomach
i never heard a man scream like i'm like
a lady i never heard a man scream like a
baby
and i got him again and right in the
neck ah
you got my [ __ ] bite
[ __ ] he said no man
he started crying like a little [ __ ] i
got him
somewhere up in here i never i mean i
remember
god damn and i i remember i remember
i went around to this because i took the
money out of his pocket
he had about 100 i went and i went to
the store and i got me some
i used to like that bosco chocolate mix
to make and chocolate milk and i was
gonna make some so i went and got the
chocolate
when i came out somebody stole the bike
so the dog was going the bike was gone
and i remember when i went home man
you can hear the share of cars coming
from all over the whole god damn
state it must have been a hundred
fighters it was manning with their
police was back in there with the
shotguns they were running through the
you were here
they was going everywhere and i always
got to thinking i said man
cause i got the gun back in the drone i
said man what if them bullies
what if their bullets come back to me
and i remember watching i remember
watching the news
and somebody they suspected who's ever i
don't know where pops got that gun from
but whoever he got that gun from they
was looking for him to take him down for
that murder
yeah i you know i i you know i don't i
don't know if i don't i don't
i don't even know if the guy died i just
know i just know you i don't know i
don't even know if the guy died
i just know that i blast him he went and
he went in the hospital and [ __ ]
what do you call that critical what do
they say when you right on the edge
they had to put him on some kind of a
machine there pretty much my machine
the ones i got him in the chest but the
one i got him somewhat it
grazed him i remember seeing like seeing
i just
when i saw that [ __ ] you know and the
weird thing about it
is i didn't feel nothing not then but
you know
now it's starting to [ __ ] with me you
know because i'd be happy i'd be having
a dream somebody's going i think i had
to dream somebody yeah [ __ ]
remember me
i'm gonna get shot up and stuff man but
that's one of the incidents
that i've never really shut up and told
nobody but i felt so much better than i
did because
i was out you know i would somebody was
always picking on me and [ __ ] just led
up to that you know so
sometimes i know when people when when
people hurt somebody
because i don't do this today i don't i
won't fight nobody i won't shoot nobody
i i'll
i get loud but i'll try anything to
avoid a fighter any kind of
confrontation and commotion and because
i i don't i cuz i know i know i go there
i know i know i can go there you know
nobody i didn't tell i know i can go
there you know sometimes
i want to go there like somebody
somebody whoop my ass with a wood
with a billy club one day i owed him
some money you know i said okay i'm
gonna let that go
nah [ __ ] you [ __ ] you paid
him for now you beat matthew he beat me
all over my leg with a
way some months and don't money but
anyway he
he he's paid him full
wait my sister all my my sister had this
great big house big state
three-story state we'd always go in and
have our christmas dinner and every
every every every every single every
single every single [ __ ] year
let me go back go back and go up so i
have my daughter
when he gets father's day it's on my
holidays when he is father's day when he
gets to her birthday
i don't know how to deal with the pain
from the remorse
why are you not taking in my daughter so
i drink
and i get drunk and when i get drunk i
drink so much till i fall out wherever i
i remember one time i was in the city i
had never been to the city before
and i was actually my i was i actually
had i was i had i was laying
my head was laying on the wet grass and
the 40 oz was right here on the floor
and the police said
hey hey sir are you okay they offered me
a ride they supported brown
they offered me already said man what's
wrong with you are you what's wrong
nothing man i'm just depressed man they
got my daughter and they got my daughter
and assistant
and i'm just depressed about it and i
remember something like i remember was
in long beach one time and i was in
front of the in front of the damn
the damn the the hot dog what you call
it the the wiener schnitzel
and i remember i woke up in the middle
of the night and people were buying
their wieners and
they didn't buy them and i'm laying on
the ground i couldn't i didn't know
how in the hell i wanted that happened
to me every single year
for for for a long time for a long long
time and then
but i would go we would go my sister
would have these these parties at her
house and all the family
my friend they kind of they kind of
buddy they kind of like the hustles like
the
huxtables and bill cosby you know like
the prince of bel-air and my family kind
of
most of my family is kind of like that
but me and my
son said we we i mean i was i was the
bum the poor i was
the loser out of the family you know i
used to think like that but i was always
you know they kicked me to the curb then
the little boy they kicked me to the
curb
my dad he's always telling me i'm gonna
really whip your ass i really want to
kick your ass i really and i was
why in the [ __ ] does he hate me so much
i really want to [ __ ] you up
you know so loud i'm at the unmatched
christmas holidays you know
it takes a lot for me to save a hundred
bucks
i save 200 to give my daughter and i
i never see it so i gave it to my niece
and she gave it to my sister
and my sister i didn't know my daughter
ever got that money so when i started a
couple of criminals ago
mr just goes oh i looked at my purse
that day and i found two hundred dollars
and i spent excited he had no money now
this is a girl got a preacher out there
and and she didn't i think so my
daughter's standing and she's looking at
me and then
she didn't say well let me give it to
you now she just
laughed it off haha i spent the money
i got so [ __ ] bad now
my family knows me when i'm drunk they
don't like me they don't like my when i
go to my
own day mama they watch they watch me
like a goddamn security guard don't let
him get
god bless her her poor husband got a
liquor bar and i didn't drink damn
all the liquor on the bar i go and i
sneak in the bar and drink like don't go
down and
[ __ ] my husband's eyeball anymore so
i quit doing that but anyway
i went over there i was sober i was
sober for one
damn i was sober i'm going to go and
have a good damn time
she's talk just took the [ __ ] money
and i
i was just thinking it was hard for me
to come it was hard for me to get that
money
like this this christmas i don't want to
do because
i don't i'm not getting this i anymore
i'm behind on my rent they've got that's
the
colby people they're allowing me to stay
there i'm behind going behind behind
friends
i'm just paying what i can as i go and
i'm trying i want to i'm trying new i
want to get another hundred hundred some
dollars to get in my daughter
all i'm gonna do is get my daughter
something on christmas what am i gonna
do so i'm thinking
i'm starting to think about that 200
that she took from me
and i you know i'm like what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
another thing my daughter has a my dog i
told my daughter i used to have this bmw
and i was and i never drove because i
was gonna give it to her 18th birthday
when they saw the car i had a car and
said i'm not i'm somebody stole the car
and i
because i and i didn't tell anybody that
i was i was it was my secret i was just
gonna
go and give it to her and so i'm i'm
telling her this on the phone and i can
you you you for y'all y'all know how
black and i could
hear her do this
[Music]
yeah yeah i could hear her do that and
that hurt me
so bad that just god just eats me up on
a holiday time i start thinking about
this [ __ ]
so anyway i called somebody in the
family last week and they told me when
she came over there she's got a car
already
i started thinking i didn't you know i
didn't i didn't have anything to do with
it
i didn't i wasn't able to get her a car
you know
all this negative stuff but but going
but going back to
the scene at the house i was sober that
time
and my family knows how i go off because
last time was over there my brother had
to tell me hey hey hey man you just need
to leave but every time i go over there
i say something stupid and i get put out
and there's a great thing he'll have to
walk down this gravy
in this canyon and walk to the bus stop
to go home and unless my nieces give me
a ride
so i'm over there and
she does this [ __ ] and you know i play
the piano so she has a
grand piano in her house i sit down and
play the piano to give my mana what she
did
get off my piano don't you see that
stuff i got my christmas stuff on top of
the piano
get away from the piano
i looked at the [ __ ] i said okay wait i
still didn't say nothing
i didn't say nothing so i started my
little my little let my little london
fall caught on
and i was i started pacing i stopped
petting my mother my mother know my
mother my mother watching me
mama say oh [ __ ] down with oh [ __ ]
donald put down the dumb facts x2 he can
act like a [ __ ] i'm patient i'm pacing
up i didn't say
nothing i said susie get the food ready
because
she gives me all her food she oh man she
gets these great big fat shrimps she got
all this
what this big what you call that meat
the the brisket tea gets all this
and these real real classic expensive
meats they make
they make me sick because i'm using the
[ __ ] down here but they make me sick
but i love that good meat
i eat my [ __ ] i [ __ ] for three days why
you didn't even go
see that's why i like to laugh when i
get to the end so then so then so then
now now now now shot says hey hey go
ahead and um
put the food in the bag so i can go she
said
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] do you think
you're you know harder than me and mom
she's been dreaming you know i hired me
in my mother's [ __ ] house
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you i'm giving you my [ __ ]
food
and i'm standing there look
this is like my my friend when we had
these little dinners it's like it's you
go to the doctor's name all you thought
talk talk talk that's how it sounds in
the house the whole [ __ ] house you
could have heard her and say
hey doc hey louis you could have heard
that's how quiet everybody everybody
shut the [ __ ] up because they look
everybody all
eyes was on me because louis tender go
off my brothers they said
they said louis about to lose his
[ __ ] grip and i know it
you know what i did i took the food i
set it on the counter i walked outside
i stopped i started pacing out my mother
ran outside i'm saying here
your knees are going to get you going
you can call your uber to get you out of
the water you need to
call your uber to get you home guys get
you home i didn't say nothing
i didn't scream i didn't holler i didn't
do none of that [ __ ] they didn't know
anything i do
and it blew the whole family's mind they
said lewis didn't go off
and i feel so good because i didn't go
off on the [ __ ] but
that night we left thank you that night
we left because when we
there there was on thanksgiving last
year there was a guy who got hit by a
car
this homeless dude who got hit by a car
three times and the uber driver it was
raining and the uber driver
was watching it he said look look
they're running they kill the man
they're killing the man
and i was so mad at my sister i remember
i was just trying to look at him i was
looking at my phone so you know the next
day i heard on the news that this guy
got hit by
and the girl hit the guy in the car and
drunk him up in the gas and got out the
car and looked at him back to crop and
left
oh god but i was right there i would i
could have saw it all
but i was so mad at her you know so i i
never said anything so the next time i
saw her
oh got hurt i mean you you could tell
she was
oh she was she was coming you're talking
oh she looked like carter lewis i love
you so much come here either way what do
you need you need some money you need to
know she was just kissed
she was sucky sucky second taking
pictures of me and her sucky because
because she apologized she apologized to
me you know she was she was all sucky
sucky kissy
ass you taking pictures of me and all
this other [ __ ] because
look because she has a she has a
three-story state but then my other
sister where my daughter stayed they
have a
very very nice house it's not gonna
dissolve you know so
so also other family went there
instead of wanting her out so her her
dad her husband's family was there so i
was gonna i went there to pick up my
mother to take her home because i had my
brother's car so when i got there oh she
goes i was going
from the family there so she needed to
make her feel okay
because my brother just died recently
died so to make her feel okay she needs
some family there and i
thought she i was she was just happy to
see me but you know i'm not i'm not
but the anger the anger went away you
know i love my i love myself i love to
share my sisters
so the anger went away and you know i i
feel better she feel better and um
everything pretty much worked out okay
you know and it's gonna work out okay
today i'm gonna leave him i'm gonna come
and call on my phone cause i got
i'm gonna call him my family and just
say hey
happy thanksgiving because i have a
phone i have a phone it never rings i
i don't know but i got obama phone so i
got to use it once and once someone i
just called just to call i called the
damn
the the answer service on it to see if
anybody called nobody never called me
no man who thinks about me i met this
little lady though she's she might be
she might be a winner over there but
anyway
um that that that about ends the story
what uh
i want to make one up real quick
i sit at the house and i look so gloomy
i don't know what know what to happen
what nobody's going to do to me i knew
it was a holiday i said what am i going
to do
i'm going to call up marky mark and see
what he want me to be in his crew
so i come on down and see what i can say
i don't know what i'm going to say
tonight
but i came on down to this [ __ ]
anyway and i bet when i told this story
i bet i did that [ __ ] [ __ ]
right
when i think about this [ __ ] it come
free from the mind i can't spell it
right on no damn pen
but [ __ ] that [ __ ] when i come down
every time when i watch that dog god
damn it i'll win
so what i want to say to each and
everybody on this kind of play
is have a damn good thanksgiving
day i'm out
you